[Music]
Trump is not shocking to me because if
you look at the signs if you look at the
signs as far as what's been resonating
with all different types of groups of
people in America in terms of
entertainment in terms of literature in
terms of popular culture and now in
terms of politics you know like why did
the Tea Party thing resonate the way
that it did for so many people because
of ignorance because of this haphazard
ignorant because of a fear of looking at
oneself in the mirror and clearly
grasping the broader picture when the
Oprah Winfrey Show was enormous and she
had like racist and skinheads on my Klan
members and skinheads on once and I
remember her ass and they and the
children of them who no longer
identified with that and there were
three children on stage I think I mean
I'm remembering from way back watching
this thing as a kid and there were like
three kids on stage who had all
continued their education right and no
longer identified with being races or
having parents in the Klan or their
skinhead friends right and so she asked
the audience who's composed of all Klan
members and skinheads how many people
here graduated from high school two or
three raised their hands how many of you
went to college nobody raised their
hands asked the three kids you know who
no longer identified with their
upbringing how many of you graduates my
school how many of you went to college
so all of a sudden they had interacted
with more people in their life they got
out of their little circle and suddenly
saw the world differently
that's why cults try to keep you in try
to keep you from seeing what's out there
so that you can maintain this
perspective regardless of how warped it
may be you know yeah as you can see I'm
really into the idea of education I
think it's the I think it's the key to
all of this and I think when I see
people following Trump I think it's just
a lack of that you know I it's that
simple and because it's funny because
it's funny well I mean that we've
learned to laugh at stupid shit you know
like like I said when you equate
entertainment with escapism that what
the fuck does that mean for Bob Marley
what the fuck does that mean for Nina
Simone or Fela Kuti or Jim Morrison or
the Beatles like these cats weren't
necessarily Bob Dylan these cats weren't
necessarily trying to escape they were
digging into what was happening in the
culture like look at what's happening
around you look at what the fuck I mean
listen to the words of like satisfaction
by the stones you know the man on the TV
says this you know like these are people
who are counterculture even though you
know questioning Authority questioning
what's going on you know res now you
have a pop culture that's centered
around you know this sort of thing of
just like rooting for the winner which
is crazy to me like we I thought you've
rooted for the like for the underdog you
know but you look at like the the thing
in pop culture which like Meek Mill and
Drake for example right and people were
like the guy who's winning that's a guy
want to win you know as opposed to the
guy who actually comes from the real
fucked up situation who actually has
something to say no I want the guy who's
winning to win you know that's where we
are right now it's a fucked place in in
in in in in pop consciousness you know
and and Trump is is is the perfect
example of that like we're all like his
fucking apprentice right now like it's
it's a it's a damn shame but it was a
damn shame when he was on that show and
everybody was fucking watching it all
that shit was a damn shame this is that
outcome of that this is the outcome of
that
the ship we were laughing and then you
know calling our guilty pleasure you
know so but do you fuckin it's bad what
do you expect
[Music]
no he won't get elected as president he
won't he won't I mean like if he does
call me back here and I'll be like you
but you'll have to buy an international
ticket